so why would someone like me get
involved with a campaign to end female
genital mutilation I first of all became
a freelancer but then went off and did
vso with firstly in Cambodia and then
last year I went to Ethiopia I'd got
this impression of Africa that I'd seen
in the movies and which was full of
joyous women I suppose very
stereotypical and Ethiopia was just so
different than so many confusing mixed
messages so yes women were incredibly
beautiful and an amazing awesome dignity
but that joyousness I didn't find and I
sort of expected to and so I started
asking around a bit more about women's
issues I learned a little bit of Amharic
so I was able to interact with women a
little bit um but a woman took me to do
one side one day and said you do realize
women in Ethiopia cut and that euphemism
meant nothing to me no I didn't realize
and so I started to explore a bit more
and of course that was when I discovered
really what cut meant which means that
their external genitals are cut out
basically that was one moment I remember
very clearly in my journey the second
moment was meeting an amazing
woman who's been campaigning for 60
years on this and asking her do I have a
mandate to do this because I was getting
scared as a woman from the West you know
what right do I have to basically
practice what is no never wears cultural
imperialism cultural relativism putting
my view on to pull entire countries and
communities and she SAT me down and
looked at me and she said would you
campaign against torture yeah she said
well they can a white man campaign
against torture of black women and I
said yes of course and she said well
that's what you're doing this voice
needs to be heard you've got to be heard
and in that moment it was as if I had a
blessing as if i had a sanction from
someone who was right in the thick of
this debate as if she said you know go
forth who do what you can bring this
issue out in the open break the taboo
break the silence and do something about
it